sister assigned to D class
[Music] I'm the one who's
embarrassed I
don't have the strength or qualifications to leave this school right now
Know that  It's the
first time I've heard that kind of voice Did you learn
good moves?If it's
piano
[music]
and calligraphy, come to think of it, there was a new student who scored 50 in the subject before the entrance exam this year.
I'm scared of coincidences that I've aimed for You're
quite a unique man, Sparrow To be honest, I was
surprised that you had a friend He's
not a friend, he
's just a classmate As
usual, you seem to misunderstand the meaning of loneliness here and loneliness  If you want to
go up to the upper class, go crazy
[music]